et notre invité politique aujourd'hui
c'est julien aubert le député les
républicains du vaucluse qu'on retrouve
en duplex de carpentras bonjour julien
aubert
bonjour alors nous sommes ensemble pour
une interview d'une vingtaine de minutes
et on va commencer déjà par une première
question sur et bien les 70 ans du règne
de la reine d'angleterre est bien une en
français ce qu'il faut avoir une
admiration vis-à-vis de cette femme qui
a quand même obtenu l'unité de son pays
malgré à des guerres et des crises
pendant 70 ans
écoutez oui une forme d'admiration pour
la reine d'angleterre
être chef d'état c'est un jeu stérile
c'est une charge très lourde je crois
qu'on ne voit que les aspects positifs
en termes d'image ou les avantages qui
sont liées comme d'avoir un très beau
château mais arrêtez vous n'avez pas de
vie vous n'avez plus de vie privée et
donc je crois qu'elle a traversé
beaucoup de crises à la fois publiques
et privées et que effectivement elle a
bien mérité de la part des britanniques
cet attachement et cette fierté une
célébration qui est bien méritée alors
julien ouvert ce matin on va revenir et
bien en détail sur cette audition de au
sénat de gérald darmanin le ministre
l'intérieur et de la ministre des sports
sur le fiasco l'organisation de la
finale de la ligue des champions samedi
soir au stade de france avec quand même
une forme de mea culpa du ministre de
l'intérieur sur et bien une stratégie de
fraude massive des faux billets qui
n'avait pas du tout été anticipée par la
police et son administration et puis
également en usage disproportionné du
gaz lacrymogène sur des familles des
enfants des jeunes supporters également
des conduites inappropriées de la part
de certains policiers il était temps de
faire ce mec ce mea culpa pour gérald
darmanin selon vous
c'était un mea culpa très léger compte
tenu à la fois 2 de l'inefficacité d'une
durée du service d'ordre qui étaient
autour du stade de france et compte tenu
des je dirais des zones nombre car
immédiatement il ya une version
officielle qui était démentie par les
témoignages de ceux qui étaient présents
ce qui est gênant bon il ya deux choses
que l'on ne sache pas encadrer un grand
événement sportif c'est effectivement un
petit peu
perturbant
pour l'avenir compte tenu des jeux
olympiques du rugby ce qui est plus
embêtant c'est qu'on est un ministre qui
s'accroche à une version officielle que
de toute évidence
les je dirais les acteurs présentent
démentent avec des chiffres qui ont
circulé sur le nombre de faux billets
voilà qui met je dirais sur la sellette
la parole publique la crédibilité du
ministre de l'intérieur et du ministre
des sports tim est sur la sellette
également le ministre de l'intérieur
lui-même selon vous
oui parce qu'ils étaient présents et
parce qu'il est à l'auteur je dirais de
l'auteur de cette version officielle
considérant qu'il fallait surtout blâmer
les supporters anglais
et ne pas parler des autres sujets
autour du stade de france vous savez on
a besoin d'avoir confiance dans le
ministre de l'intérieur on a besoin
d'avoir confiance dans sa parole là on
n'a ni confiance dans son efficacité ni
confiance dans la version qu'il donne et
on a eu l'étrange sentiment d'ailleurs
qu'il était quelque peu détaché et qu'il
allait utiliser la nouvelle ministre des
sports comme paratonnerre pour ce qui
est quand même principalement de l'ordre
de sa responsabilité donc oui je crois
si vous voulez qu'effectivement il est
venu devant le sénat qu'il a esquissé un
timide mea culpa mais que comme
d'habitude il n'y a pas de
responsabilité dans un sujet comme celui
ci je pense que le ministre de
l'intérieur aurait pu à minima proposé
au premier ministre sa démission alors
le ministre prenne ministre est pas
obligé de l'accepter mais au moins il ya
le geste symbolique de reconnaître qu'il
a failli
vous demandez également la démission du
préfet de police de paris didier
lallement qui est lui était responsable
directement
du caractère opérationnel de ce
dispositif
alors moi ce qui m'interpelle je dirais
dans la manière dont on a géré les
choses c'est l' usage disproportionné de
la force que des enfants ou des gens
pacifiques se fasse gaz est
systématiquement ça commence à poser un
vrai sujet mais ça n'est pas la première
fois que la question de l'usagé de la
force se pose et je ne suis pas du genre
si vous voulez a condamné les violences
policières moi j'ai pleinement confiance
dans la police en revanche je pense
qu'il ya une doctrine d'emploi de la
force qu'il y a une forme d'expérience
par rapport à certains types de
mouvements de foule et que si vous
mettez des policiers qui ne sont pas
suffisamment formés à cela vous pouvez
effectivement aboutir à un résultat
optimal donc je me rappelle notamment la
la manière dont la crise des gilets
jaunes avaient été gérées je crois qu'il
faudrait effectivement s'interroger ce
n'est pas moi qui nomme les préfets mais
la responsabilité est d'abord politique
parce que je dirais que c'est avant tout
une forme de flou ou de mensonges sur la
parole publique est ce que gérald
darmanin sous-estiment les violences de
bandes de jeunes qu'on a vu samedi soir
des phénomènes de délinquance qui se
sont ajoutés aussi à ce phénomène des
faux billets une délinquance qui est
dénoncé par en tout cas qui a été
dénoncée hier par la sénatrice de droite
jacqueline eustache brinio et qui est
dénoncé dans ce débat depuis quelques
jours par l'extrême droite
moi je ne sais pas s'il a sous-estimé je
crois qu'il y as mal aise dans ce pays
pour désigner et pour mettre des mots
sur quelque chose on va vous dire ce
sont des jeunes non ce ne sont pas des
jeunes et une jeunesse de france et qui
n'a rien à voir avec les énergumènes qui
ont pris d'assaut le stade de france on
va vous dire ce sont des immigrés non ce
ne sont pas des immigrés pour beaucoup
ce sont des gens qui sont français on a
un problème si vous les deux de mettre
des mots de peur de choquer de peur de
stigmatiser comme on dit et on en vient
au point même finalement qu'on ne nomme
plus ou qu'on ne ne mentionne plus ces
événements là et pourtant il existe et
on sait que c'est un des moteurs de soi
de la colère soit de la peur car un
grand nombre de français se disent mais
comment est ce qu'un événement comme je
dirais cette voie là cet événement
sportif au stade de france peut ainsi
tourné à la razzia est-ce qu'on est
encore en sécurité pourquoi est ce que
la police n'est pas capable d'assurer la
protection de ceux qui viennent assister
au match et ça n'est pas la première
fois qu'il ya des débordements et ça
n'est pas la première fois que dans le
93 se pose des questions de sécurité et
derrière des questions tout simplement
des simulations à la société parce que
on ne se comporte pas comme ça dans un
pays civilisé donc je crois que cette
question là c'est la mauvaise conscience
si vous voulez de de notre pays il y a
une forme de quelque part d' aveuglement
du gouvernement parce que c'est le point
noir de son bilan parce que peut-être
ils n'osent pas dire non plus toute la
vérité et du coup on profite à 100 de
gens qui font fantasmer ou qui en
profitent pour agiter des épouvantails
alors qu'il s'agit d'abord de maintien
de l'ordre et d'assimilation
républicaine alors julien aubert on va
parler de la visite du président de la
république emmanuel macron aujourd'hui à
marseille en déplacement sur le thème de
l'école qui est d'ailleurs fait avec son
nouveau ministre de l'éducation
nationale pap ndiaye emmanuel macron qui
va visiter nicole une école du 10e
arrondissement de marseille ou xp ou
expérimentés son projet d'école du futur
avec plus de liberté pédagogique dans ce
projet est également plus de liberté et
d'autonomie pour les directeurs d'école
qu'est ce que vous attendez du président
de république en matière d'éducation
beaucoup alors malheureusement pas avec
ce ministre je crois que c'est la
meilleure
démonstration si vous voulez de de
l'incroyable cynisme du président de la
république il a nommé à la suite de
quelqu'un qui faisait du rock isp et du
communautarisme ça je dirais son ennemi
numéro un un ministre qui émarge
largement justement à ce courant de
pensée dans une société fracturée ou au
contraire il faut insister pour
assimiler il faut insister au contraire
sur le fait que indépendamment de la
couleur de peau indépendamment des
origines nous sommes français c'est
d'abord la citoyenneté c'est le fait
d'aimer ce pays son histoire sa culture
et moi je préférerais qu'on insiste sur
sa plutôt que sur le racisme structurel
ceci étant dit en introduction
c'est bien l'école du futur je crois que
l'idée dé pas stupide de faire une
expérimentation pour la liberté
pédagogique je suis très content pour
les établissements qui sont concernés
maintenant il ya quand même l'école du
présent et l'école du présent c'est une
situation d'insalubrité dans les écoles
de marseille où le président la pluie
qui avait annoncé qu'il ferait des this
man de rénovation je pense qu'avant de
parler de liberté pédagogique il aurait
d'abord fallu
achevé ce plan d'investissement ou en
tout cas le lancer et concurremment
peut-être mettre en place cette liberté
pédagogique puis deuxièmement une
expérimentation c'est bien pour 59
établissements je crois que c'est toute
l'école qui souffre et on ne peut pas
attendre je dirais que l'expérimentation
se termine pour aller vite on en a des
rapports on pourrait même construire
beaucoup d'écoles en france avec tous
les rapports qu'on a écrit sur l'école
donc j'attends signé du président de la
république premièrement qu'il arrête de
fermer les classes scolaires en milieu
rural deuxièmement qu'il donne la
liberté de recrutement au directeur de
l'établissement pour qu'ils aient la
main sur leur équipe troisièmement on
qu'on arrête avec le nivellement par le
bas du corps professoral en considérant
que n'importe qui qui poussent la porte
sans avoir d'ailleurs le moins de
formation pédagogique ou sur le fonds
puisse devenir un bon professeur qu'on
arrête de galvauder ce beau métier qui
est qui est professeur des écoles ou
professeurs tout court d'ailleurs parce
que on leur confie la jeunesse et quand
vous voyez de l'autre côté et bien nous
non je dirais le classement pisa de la
france en mathématiques le niveau
d'orthographe et de grammaire qui est
catastrophique on se rend bien compte
que il est urgent de renforcer le
primaire de renforcer les savoirs
principaux donc hélas aussi d'ailleurs
il ya une question à se poser c'est à
dire que c'est bien la liberté
pédagogique c'est bien d'aller faire la
natation ou du basket mais on doit avoir
à l'entrée la 6è rang 6e des jeunes
français qui connaissent leur histoire
la géographie de ce pays qui savent lire
écrire compter et ce serait déjà très
très bien et aujourd'hui ça n'est pas le
cas et oui l'importance des savoirs
fondamentaux julien aubert vous dites on
embauche n'importe qui aujourd'hui pour
devenir professeur mais aujourd'hui une
grave crise de recrutement dans
l'éducation nationale comment on fait
pour rendre ce métier plus attractif et
ce qu'il faut encore revaloriser les
professeurs et ce qu'il faut leur
demander d'avoir de nouvelles missions
de travailler plus comme le fait
emmanuel macron dans son programme et
rendez vous compte si on faisait ça pour
les médecins dans les hôpitaux on manque
de médecins et dont vous savez quoi eh
bien on va faire un speed dating ceux
qui veulent devenir médecin vous passez
la porte on vous fait trois jours de
formation et demain vous serez
généralistes spécialistes les gens
eurent leur est donc non on ne peut pas
répondre à une crise d'attractivité du
corps professoral que je dirais par ce
genre de solution évidemment c'est bien
qu'ils aient des jambes qui sont en
reconversion maintenant effectivement il
ya le sujet je dirais de 2,2 du point
d'indicé la bonification indiciaire des
fonctionnaires l'éducation nationale il
ya un sujet aussi de l'adaptation de
l'école aujourd'hui on sait bien qu'il y
a des quartiers très compliqué que
l'école se retrouve à devoir gérer aussi
des choses qui ne sont pas de sa mission
ce n'est pas à l'école d'éduquer les
enfants elle est là pour instruire même
s'ils s'appellent l'éducation nationale
il ya une grande partie d'abord qui
doivent être faites par les familles le
problème c'est que quand vous récupérez
déjà même à l'âge de trois ans des
enfants qui ne sont pas propres parce
que les parents ne leur ont pas repris
ou qui ne parle pas français parce qu'on
ne parle pas français à la maison et
bien vous pouvez même pas me mettre en
place un programme de maternelle et ça
ce n'est pas le rôle si vous voulez de
ces de ces jeunes professeurs donc tu
vois les gars il faut prendre conscience
de l'évolution de la société augmente et
effectivement les salles et je pense les
traitements de fonctionnaires revoir
notre mode d'organisation permettent
plus de mobilité aussi parce que vous
avez des parfois des professeurs qui
sont dans des zones sensibles et qui est
maître 10 15 ans avant de pouvoir en
échappée donc ils finissent par se se
décourager et en réalité c'est en
remontant le niveau de l'école publique
qui aujourd'hui est déserté par
notamment les bonnes familles qui tout
en expliquant que le public sait très
bien mettre leurs enfants dans le privé
parce qu'ils savent très bien l'état
aujourd'hui l'école publique c'est en
remontant au niveau de l'école publique
qu'on permettra aussi d'avoir des jeux
dirait des environnements plus plus
agréable pour ces enseignants parce
qu'aujourd'hui se concentrent ont
parfois des publics très compliqué
julien aubert on va évoquer une autre
crise celle de l'hôpital avec la
fermeture de nombreux services d'urgence
sur notre territoire emmanuel macron
annoncé une mission d'information flash
d'un mois pour dresser le constat et les
besoins pour les hôpitaux en france avec
également une conférence sur la santé
est ce que ces annonces sont à la
hauteur du problème et de l'urgence
mais non je pensais moi qu'on sortait
d'une élection présidentielle une
élection présidentielle c'est fait pour
débattre des grands sujets donc on n'a
pas débattu de la santé d'ailleurs
pourquoi est-ce qu'on n'a pas débattu de
la santé parce que président de la
république ne voulait pas débattre mais
la suppression des urgences c'est pas
maintenant il ya encore deux ans
rappelez vous c'est semoun ces grands
professeurs qui avaient signé un
manifeste en disant nous on va finir par
démissionner de l'hôpital public est là
une mission flash mais là encore avec le
nombre de rapports qu'on a écrit sur la
station de l'hôpital on n'a pas besoin
de rapports on a besoin d'un président
de la république et d'un gouvernement
qui prenne des mesures à prendre des
mesures c'est considérait effectivement
qu'il ya à prendre d'attractivité que
pour les gens qui font des gardes de
nuit dans l'ambulatoire ou dans
l'hôpital où des gardes week-end et bien
c'est insuffisamment attractifs peut il
ya des situations d'intérim de médecins
qui font de l'intérim qui du coup je
dirais ivre de sa est donc passé vous
avez un déséquilibre financier avec ce
que les médecins qui eux sont à plein
temps dans ces hôpitaux que vous avez
parfois des praticiens qui met les
collectivités locales en concurrence
dans le domaine de l'ambulatoire par
rapport aux services annexes qu'on peut
le ramener donc c'est très pervers comme
si tu es sûr qu'il y a un problème de
partage des compétences parce qu'il ya
des actions que les médecins font mais
qui devraient être transférés à des âges
amis qui sont tout à fait en capacité de
le faire si on veut des charges et qu'
il ya une expression évidemment du
pilotage administratif de ces hôpitaux
qui est beaucoup trop centralisée on n'a
pas arrêté de parler de décentralisation
mais la réalité c'est que quand on a
supprimé midas une direction
départementale et qu'on a créé les ars
agences régionales on a centralisé on a
centralisé au plan régional le pilotage
de la santé redonnons je dirais le
pouvoir de décision au niveau des
établissements hors voyons le partage
des rôles entre l'administratif et les
praticiens libéraux aussi l'exercice
l'exercice ambulatoire district 6 en
libéral voila voila il essayons aussi de
mieux de mieux protéger les
établissements de proximité dans la
circonscription j'ai un hôpital dont on
a fermé la maternité le vrai problème de
fond c'est pas le problème seulement d'
emmanuel macron ça fait malheureusement
25 ans on essaye de piloter la santé au
travers d'indicateurs financiers avec
l'ondam donc s'adonner sans doute de
très bons résultats au plan comptable
face à un plomb dames c'est la hausse
des dépenses d'assurance-maladie chacun
6 tentera de faire exploser le système
ça alors je me contente de faire
exploser le système parce que vous avez
des gens qui mettent six mois vous
remettre ça alors julien aubert sur le
bureau des manuels macron il ya un autre
dossier qui concerne et bien la sécurité
sociale et plus précisément le régime
des retraites c'est la réforme des
retraites et ce dossier il pourrait être
mis de côté car eh bien on apprend qu
emmanuel macron pourrait reculer sur la
réforme des retraites au l'idée au
départ ils voulaient repousser l'âge à
65 ans après finalement c'est plutôt 64
ans avec une clause de revoyure voyeur
et finalement et bien l'option d'une
simple hausse de la durée de cotisation
pour être envisagée est ce que ça vous
inquiète ce flou sur la réforme des
retraites d'emmanuel macron
alors au plan politique d'abord quand
même une petite critique habituelle
macro propos prévoit de repousser l'âge
de la retraite ils prévoyaient
finalement il termine en repoussant la
réforme elle même sans clause de
revoyure d'air si je vous comprends donc
c'est quand même problématique en termes
de parole publique parce qu'il ya eu une
élection présidentielle où le président
de la république a tenu un discours
différent même si entre les deux tours
au fur et à mesure de ses pérégrinations
et de sa rencontre avec le peuple
français l'âge de la retraite mais c'est
bon mais le deuxième sujet c'est que moi
je suis favorable à ce que effectivement
on discute sur le nombre de durée de
cotisation le nombre de durée de
trimestres de cotisation parce que c'est
plus égalitaire un âge de la retraite ça
dépend beaucoup du métier que vous avez
fait et ça doit pas être un totem vous
avez des gens qui veulent parce qu'ils
peuvent travailler plus vous en avez
d'autres idées métier très difficile
donc parlons plutôt d'une durée de
cotisation ce qui permet d'ailleurs de
prendre effectivement en compte le début
de la carrière après on sait qu'au plan
financier
quand on raisonne comme ça c'est moins
efficace maintenant vous avez eu la
réforme touraine qui doit rentrer en
vigueur dans quelques années on pourrait
l'avancé de manière effectivement avoir
un effet de rééquilibrage je crois qu'il
faut être très pragmatique là dessus ce
dont les gens ont peur aujourd'hui pour
ceux qui ont eu des métiers pénibles
c'est finalement de se retrouver à
cotiser plus longtemps et si on est
juste mais en panneaux on doit pas
traiter de la même manière on doit pas
avoir le même âge pour celui qui est
dans les bureaux ou qui comme moi fait
une activité non manuel et celui qui
dans la rue tous les jours rookie ou qui
dans des champs comme un agriculteur
alors julien aubert on va évoquer la
politique la campagne des élections
législatives et l'enjeu pour votre party
les républicains dans cette campagne
alors je le précise vous avez une
centaine de députés sortants à
l'assemblée nationale et selon les
saunas les sondages notamment selon le
dernier sondage ifop d'hier et bien les
républicains pourraient avoir seulement
entre 35 et à 55 sièges vous craignez
que votre effectif à l'assemblée ne font
de moitié
moi je suis si vous voulez très très
suspicieux sur ce genre de sondage
national parce que dans la pratique si
vous dites à quelqu'un dans la rue allez
vous voter les républicains il va vous
dire ah bah non parce qu'il ya eu ceci
ou cela après si vous leur dites mais
est-ce que vous allez pour qui vous
allez voter aux législatives ah bah j'ai
voté pour monsieur x qui par ailleurs
est longue des républicains mais je
l'aimé bien parce que lui c'est un bon
député donc si ça ça marche si vous
voulez dans dans 180 circonscription
vous risquez d'avoir un résultat très
différent les gens font une distinction
entre l'étiquette et l'homme est une
élection législative en tout cas dans
les territoires ruraux c'est quand même
d'abord le choix d'une personnalité avec
des députés les républicains qui sont
très ancrées moi j'ai en plus une
trentaine de candidats qui ont demandé
le soutien de la france maintenant que
je préside et il réalise qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont en attente si
oui d'abord d'un renouveau et ensuite
d'une droite qui soit non macro nier
mais qui soit clairement indépendantes
sans risque si vous voulez de
compromission et je crois que c'est ça
que vous rapportez les sortants qui ne
sont pas allés se rallier à emmanuel
macron ce sont des résistants si vous
bien que les gens comprennent aussi
c'est que les républicains sont en fait
le seul parti pas seulement un parti
d'opposition c'est un parti d'alternance
la différence avec la nuque qui est une
coalition hétéroclite du moment en mode
auberge espagnole où leur assemblée
nationale c'est que ils peuvent être des
forces d'opposition mais qu'on a bien
compris au moment des élections
présidentielles que arrivé au second
tour ne peut pas y avoir d'alternance
donc si un jour les français ne veulent
plus de ce grand parti gloubiboulga
centrale encore présentes là ma
chronique qui ne tient que par la
passion et emmanuel macron 1 qui oscille
entre blancs caire et pas penda et
darmana et dupond moretti il n'y a que
les républicains qui peut offrir une
plate forme suffisante pour 2027 obtenir
cette alternance et julien aubert si le
19 6 le 19 juin au soir eh bien les
candidats ensemble emmanuel macron
n'obtiennent qu'une majorité relative à
l'assemblée nationale et que par exemple
ils sont obligés de gouverner avec et
bien des dizaines de députés les
républicains est ce que vous vous êtes
prêt à un contrat de gouvernement avec
allemagne emmanuel macron et sous
quelles conditions
non je crois que s'il ya une majorité
simple il y aura un gouvernement qui
sera à 6,7 majorité simple est que les
républicains dans cette perspective eh
bien d'abord il y aura un vrai débat à
l'assemblée nationale ce sera une
internationale plurielle et parce qu'on
a connu avec une majorité pléthorique
qui n'écoutaient
ni personne et donc sur chaque texte il
y aura une discussion on n'est pas
obligé de faire un contrat de
gouvernement moi je suis pas monsieur
hamad moi je veux pas être ministre de
monsieur nagrand moi ce que je veux en
revanche c'est que lorsqu'on vient à
parler de la réforme des retraites eh
bien nous défendrons nos positions et
ils seront bien obligés d'accepter voilà
pourquoi d'ailleurs il faut voter pour
les républicains
c'est la meilleure certains aiment la
belgique si on veut avoir aujourd'hui
une orientation à droite c'est la
meilleure je dirais assurance qu'on peut
donner parce que la macro ni c'est une
espèce de culbuto vous ne savez jamais
de quel côté ça peut tomber il peut très
bien gouvernée par deux ans à gauche et
depuis deux ans à droite vous n'en savez
rien en revanche effectivement si vous
avez une majorité simple avec à fort
groupe l'est républicain bien il y aura
un fil à la patte et vous pourrez faire
pression sur le gouvernement dernière
question julien baer sur l'avenir de
votre party les républicains on sait que
le président du parti christian jacob va
quitter ses fonctions après les
élections législatives vous vous dit
intéressé par le poste quand est ce que
vous allez vous lancer à présenter votre
candidature et puis sur quelle ligne
politique pour votre parti
d'abord on est candidat lorsqu'on est
élu réélu moi j'ai d'abord si vous
voulez un contrat avec les vauclusiens
je leur propose un bilan je leur dis
voilà ce que j'ai fait et voilà ce que
je veux faire ça veut de me dire s'il
souhaite que ça continue ou pas ensuite
s'il me renouvellent leur confiance
alors dans ce cas là je me sentirai
démocratiquement et en termes de
légitimité suffisamment fort pour
proposer une offre politique
une offre qui est différente de celle
qui a été fait auparavant je crois si
vous voulez que aujourd'hui on doit
mieux prendre en compte les
préoccupations des territoires dits
périphériques des classes moyennes et
populaires que la doctrine économique
des républicains doit rester libéral
mais qu'elle doit se
renouveler profondément notamment sur
tout ce qui est mise en concurrence
libre échange que le monde a changé que
la mondialisation est en train de
s'inverser qu'il faut désormais plaidé
pour plus de protectionnisme d'
équilibre en matière écologique et
sociale je crois aussi qu'il faut
aborder des sujets qui ne sont pas
abordés la relation par exemple de la
question à l'animal je crois que nous
avons des débats internes à trancher par
exemple de savoir si nous défendons la
commune le département ou la région
parce que quand on défend les trois en
même temps et qu'en même temps on
prétend faire des économies eh bien on
n'a rien résolu voilà et donc oui
derrière il ya un mode d'organisation
politique donc ça s'appelle le gaullisme
ça s'appelle une certaine idée de la
france ça s'appelle renouer avec la
nation et la défense de la nation et du
peuple français comme logica objectif
prioritaire face à un président de la
république qui est tout et rien et qui
est nulle part et ailleurs en tout cas
qui n'est pas sur la nation parce qu'il
est en train lentement de fédéraliser le
système européen avec une fuite en avant
notamment au niveau énergétique ou au
niveau budgétaire sans en référer aux
français et ce sera le mot de la fin
merci beaucoup julien aubert d'avoir été
à notre invité politique aujourd'hui
[Musique]